hello hello thank you
is this how it's normally served in a
to-go box yes you pay $100 a night to
stay here and you got to eat your food
out of boxes and plastic containers are
we short of soup
it's not even half full that's nothing
serve it that much yes that's one cup
it's like a retirement home is that
luxury do you think no not at all what
would you rather do
sip that out of a cup of course we've
barely got half a cup anyway and I'm
diggin if there's anything else I can do
for you just go ahead and let us look
okay brilliant mm-hmm darling I'm sorry
you say that now it's finished thank you
my pleasure
a chicken parmesan slider master now I
know why they got the boxes is to take
away poop box Pizza unappetizing in a
box especially when you're spending $800
a night where are the crab cakes
oh that's them there underneath there
are they mini crab cakes so we the chef
has decided that those are of the size
that he needs to serve em hmm I mean
that taste threatened that thing takes
sort of washy and soapy and $20 for them
he's as cheap with these crab cakes as
he is with his style now for the lamb
with Roberts ridiculous $15 extra charge
its rack of lamb and crusted in
macadamia nuts fresh herbs and a little
bit of Dijon mustard it's served with a
honey vinegar reduction it's not even
cooked properly rested
I was getting nervous when you see white
fat like that on the side of the shop to
your liking I mean it's pretty raw in
the center you like the flavor of it
though the honey Karen no way too sweet
I'm not satisfied with the quality the
food's coming out of the kitchen I
believe our chef has a learning curve to
be where he needs to be thank you we
just lost our other chef why did the
chef leave I supposed to tell you the
truth right the truth is all I want to
know why did the chef leave well her
paycheck she put all their everything on
her charge Kotzen and she just beckoned
she wasn't paid back for what she's chef
bought produce she did she did
everything she was the best chef ever
probably those dreadful
I'm starving the peanut butter chocolate
decadence I could do with some that pick
me up please
thank you guard I shift that left
because you have to buy produce on her
own credit card I mean this guy's
priorities are upside down
hey are you ready this he said he
doesn't care for a sweet 'no sis fat
around it
he didn't care for the flavor of the
honey gar
[Music]
well thank you very much and did you cut
in half because it looks like somebody
and where's the other half come I goes
to them another person who waters and I
want my other half $74 this place is
insane
listen half my desserts missing if you
think I'm spending $74 for dessert that
is half-cocked hmm actually quite nice
there is hope I'm sorry you know I mean
I'm going to say that that is not a
dessert that he made Baba made it no
somebody else makes dessert
it's ordered like store-bought like
through one of our purveyors what she's
an asparagus and it's deep fried and
comes with a jalapenos fight salmon with
cream cheese disgusting
a strange combination maybe where
doesn't work for me that one Amy's just
greasy get this out of the way as quick
as possible okay thank you my first
impressions of the food here is that
it's as bad as the rooms
Buda Sakura no good that thing so it's
pretty big right so how you supposed to
get it in your mouth
I've never eaten it before let's try
come on me we're in this together oh no
you order this at all on your own
show that open wine please
wait there's no way this is gonna fit my
mouth do it no no my granddad feels we
puts in your teeth it so you took one
little bite I do damn disaster total
disaster how'd it taste by the way I'm
very good the Sakura is very chewy
Sookie does tried her best but she has
no idea what she's doing
what's wrong with a Fukuda bland ugly
chewy strange combination chewy
yep and impossible to put me around let
me tell you about my sushi I'm not a
Morimoto and Noble absolutely I'm doing
my best and I respect rice what is this
one strawberry field man look at that
strawberry on sushi I'm bothering
Japanese chef in America I'd like to
apologize it's very weird which part is
so you wouldn't cover white tuna with
strawberries and then glaze it this is
crab cakes calamari with gorgonzola when
he wants the burger medium rare I am
very proud of my food whenever I eat
other places I think we're better than
90% of them
we have Palmyra in the liner off the
crab cakes um let's do this together
Jamar's please come on you're supposed
to my wingman
I I had to swallow it was not enjoyable
he'll miss for me that's a miss yes holy
[ __ ]
how was lunch my darling it wasn't very
good and everything feels institutional
rice you know like we just got out of
the hospital that's the best food again
I'm sorry it's not a nice surprise on
Mother's Day
hey cocktail sauce pork in lemon monkey
this for the marinara fried calamari
can you hear any crispy juicy that's the
link brother my granddad's dick oh my
god the calamari was mostly greasy you
know I have to bring this food out you
know he's gonna critique it and you know
I'm gonna come right back within one
second because you don't care you're
just setting me like [ __ ] on a plate
basically are these the Marshalls Mike
my bad guy thank you very much
Jesus where's my boyo what a mess did
you tell them it's medium-rare Jesus
it's wrong that is not medium-rare what
a shame that is dreadful my uncle can't
cook a burger medium-rare and freaking
kidding me